many people face the news each morning
with trepidation and dread every day we
read of shootings inequality pollution
dictatorship war and the spread of
nuclear weapons these are some of the
reasons that 2016 was called the worst
year ever until 2017 claimed that record
I left many people longing for earlier
decades when the world seemed safer
cleaner and more equals but is this a
sensible way to understand the human
condition in the 21st century as
Franklin Pierce Adams pointed out
nothing is more responsible for the good
old days than a bad memory
you can always fool yourself into seeing
a decline if you compare leaving
headlines at the present with
rose-tinted images of the past what does
the trajectory of the world look like
when we measure well-being over time
using a constant yardstick let's compare
the most recent data on the present with
the same measures thirty years ago last
year Americans killed each other at a
rate of 5.3 400,000 had 7% of their
citizens in poverty and emitted 21
million tons of particulate matter and 4
million tons of sulfur dioxide but 30
years ago the homicide rate was 8 point
5 400,000 poverty rate was 12% and we
emitted 35 million tons of particulate
matter and 20 million tons of sulfur
dioxide what about the world as a whole
last year the world had 12 ongoing Wars
60 autocracies 10 % of the world
population in extreme poverty and more
than 10,000 nuclear weapons but 30 years
ago there were 23 Wars 85 autocracies 37
% of the world population in extreme
poverty and more than 60,000 nuclear
weapons true last year was a terrible
year for terror
in Western Europe with 238 deaths but
1988 was worse with 440 deaths what's
going on it's 1988 a particularly bad
year or are these improvements a sign
that the world for all its troubles gets
better over time my tree even invoke the
admittedly old-fashioned notion of
progress to do so is to court a certain
amount of derision because I have found
that intellectuals heat progress and
intellectuals who call themselves
progressive really hate progress now
it's not that they hate the fruits of
progress mind you most academics and
pundits would rather have their surgery
with anesthesia than without it it's the
idea of progress that rankles the
chattering class if you believe that
humans can improve their lot I have been
told that means that you have a blind
faith and a quasi religious belief in
the outmoded superstition and the false
promise of the myth of the onward march
of inexorable progress you are a
cheerleader for vulgar American can-do
ISM with the rah-rah spirit of wardroom
ideology Silicon Valley and the chamber
of commerce you are a practitioner of
Whig history a naive optimist a
Pollyanna and of course a Pangloss
alluding to the Voltaire character who
declared all us for the best in the best
of all possible worlds well professor
Pangloss as it happens was a pessimist a
true optimist believes there could be
much better worlds than the one we have
today but all of this is irrelevant
because the question of whether progress
has taken place is not a matter of faith
or having an optimistic temperament or
seeing the glass as half-full
it's a testable hypothesis for all their
differences people largely agree on what
goes into human wellbeing life elf
sustenance prosperity peace freedom
safety knowledge leisure happiness all
of these things can be measured
if they have improved over time that I
submit his progress let's go to the data
beginning with the most precious thing
of all life for most of human history
life expectancy at birth was around 30
today worldwide it is more than 70 and
in the development parts of the world
more than 80 250 years ago in the
richest countries of the world a third
of the children did not live to see
their fifth birthday before the risk was
brought down a hundredfold today that
they'd be falls less than 6% of children
in the poorest countries of the world
famine is one of the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse and could bring
devastation to any part of the world
today famine has been banished to the
most remote and war ravaged regions 200
years ago 90% of the world's population
subsisted in extreme poverty today fewer
than 10% of people do for most of human
history the powerful states and empires
were pretty much always at war with each
other and peace was a mere interlude
between wars today they are never at war
with each other
the last great power war pitted the
United States against China 65 years ago
more recently wars of all kinds have
become fewer and less deadly the annual
rate of war has fallen from about 20 to
400,000 per year in the early 50s to 1.2
today democracy has suffered obvious
setbacks in Venezuela in Russia in
Turkey and is threatened by the rise of
authoritarian populism in Eastern Europe
and the United States yet the world has
never been more democratic than it has
been in the past decade with two-thirds
of the world's people living in
democracies homicide rates plunge
whenever anarchy and the code of
vendetta are replaced by the rule of law
it happened when feudal Europe was
brought under the control of centralised
kingdoms so that today a Western
European has 135th the chance of being
murdered
compared to his medieval ancestors it
happened again in colonial New England
in the American Wild West when the
sheriffs moved
and in Mexico indeed we become safer in
just about every way over the last
century we become 96% less likely to be
killed in a car crash 88 percent less
likely to be mowed down on the sidewalk
99 percent less likely to die in a plane
crash
95 percent less likely to be killed on
the job
89 percent less likely to be killed by
an act of God such as a drought flood
wildfire storm volcano landslides
earthquake or meteor strike presumably
not because god has become less angry
with us but because of him but because
of improvements in the resilience of our
infrastructure and what about the
quintessential act of God the projectile
hurled by Zeus himself yes we are 97%
less likely to be killed by a bolt of
lightning before the 17th century no
more than 15% of Europeans could read or
write
Europe and the United States achieved
universal literacy by the middle of the
20th century and the rest of the world
is catching up today more than 90
percent of the world's population under
the age of 25 can read and write in the
19th century
Westerners worked more than 60 hours per
week today they work fewer than 40
thanks to the universal penetration of
running water and electricity in the
developed world and the widespread
adoption of washing machines vacuum
cleaners refrigerators dishwashers
stoves and microwaves the amount of our
lives that we forfeit the housework has
fallen from 60 hours a week to fewer
than 15 hours a week do all these gains
in health wealth safety knowledge and
leisure make us any happier the answer
is yes in 86 percent of the world's
countries happiness has increased in
recent decades well I hope to have
convinced you that progress is not a
matter of faith or optimism but is a
fact of human history indeed the
greatest fact in human history and how
is this fact been covered in the news
a tabulation of positive and negative
emotion words in news stories as shown
during the decades in which humanity has
gotten healthier wealthier wiser safer
and happier the New York Times has
become increasingly morose and the
world's broadcast to have gotten
steadily glommer why don't people
appreciate progress part of the answer
comes from our cognitive psychology we
estimate risk using a mental shortcut
called the availability heuristic the
easier it is to recall something from
memory the more probable we judge it to
be the other part of the answer comes
from the nature of journalism captured
in this satirical headline from the
onion CNN holds warning meeting to
decide what viewers should panic about
for the rest of the day
news is about stuff that happens not
stuff that doesn't happen you never see
a journalist he says I'm reporting live
from a country that has been at peace
for 40 years or a city that has not been
attacked by terrorists also bad things
can happen quickly but good things
aren't built in a day
the papers could have run the headline
137 thousand people escaped from extreme
poverty yesterday every day for the last
25 years that's one and a quarter
billion people leaving poverty behind
but you never read about it also the
news capitalizes on our morbid interest
what can go wrong captured in the
programming policy if it bleeds it leads
well if you combine our cognitive biases
with the nature of news you can see why
the world has been coming to an end for
a very long time indeed let me address
some questions about progress that no
doubt have occurred to many of you first
isn't it good to be pessimistic to
safeguard against complacency to rake
the muck to speak truth to power
well not exactly it's good to be
accurate of course we should be aware of
suffering in danger wherever they occur
but we should also be aware of how they
can be reduced because there are dangers
to indiscriminate pessimism one of them
is fatalism if all our efforts of
improving the world have been in vain
why throw good money after bad the poor
will always be with you and since the
world will end soon if climate change
doesn't kill us all and run away
artificial intelligence well eight
natural responses to enjoy life while we
can eat drink and be merry for tomorrow
we die the other danger of thoughtless
pessimism is radicalism if our
institutions are all failing and beyond
hope for reform a natural response is to
seek to smash the Machine drain the
swamp burn the empire to the ground on
the hope that whatever rises out of the
ashes is bound to be better than what we
have now well if there is such a thing
as progress what causes it progress is
not some mystic
force or dialectic lifting us ever
higher it's not a mysterious arc of
history bending toward justice it's the
result of human efforts governed by an
idea an idea that we associate with the
18th century enlightenment namely that
if we apply reason and science that
enhance human well-being we can
gradually succeed is progress inevitable
of course not
progress does not mean that everything
becomes better for everyone everywhere
all time that would be a miracle and
progress is not a miracle but problem
solving problems are inevitable and
solutions create new problems which have
to be solved in their turn the unsolved
problems facing the world today are
gargantuan including the risks of
climate change and nuclear war but we
must see them as problems to be solved
not apocalypses in waiting and
aggressively pursue solutions like deep
decarbonisation for climate change and
global zero for nuclear war finally does
the Enlightenment go against human
nature this is an acute question for me
because I'm a prominent advocate of the
existence of human nature with all its
shortcomings and perversities in my book
a blank slate I argued that the human
prospect is more tragic than utopian and
that we are not Stardust
we are not golden and there's no way
we're getting back to the garden but my
worldview has lightened up in the 15
years since the blank slate was
published my acquaintance with the
statistics of human progress starting
with violence but now encompassing every
other aspect of our well-being has
fortified my belief that in
understanding our tribulations and woes
human nature is the problem but human
nature channel by Enlightenment norms
and institutions is also the solution
admittedly it's not easy to replicate my
own data-driven epiphany with humanity
at large some intellectuals have
responded with fury to my book
enlightenment now saying first
how dare he claimed that intellectuals
hate progress and second how dare he
claim that there has been progress with
others the idea of progress this leaves
them cold saving the lives of billions
eradicating disease feeding the hungry
teaching kids to read or in at the same
time the most common response I received
from readers is gratitude gratitude for
changing their view of the world from a
numb and helpless fatalism to something
more constructive even heroic I believe
that the ideals of the Enlightenment can
be cast as a stirring narrative and I
hope that people with greater artistic
flair and rhetorical power than I can
tell it better and spread it further we
go something like this
we are born into a pitiless universe
they think steep odds against life
enabling order and in constant jeopardy
of falling apart
we were shaped by a process that is
ruthlessly competitive we are made from
crooked timber vulnerable to illusions
self-centeredness and at times
astounding stupidity yet human nature
has also been blessed with resources
that open a space for a kind of
redemption we are endowed with the power
to combine ideas recursively have
thoughts about our thoughts we have an
instinct for language allowing us to
share the fruits of our ingenuity and
experience we are deepened with a
capacity for sympathy for pity
imagination compassion commiseration
these endowments have found ways to
magnify their own power the scope of
language has been augmented by the
written printed and electronic word our
circle of sympathy has been expanded by
history journalism and the narrative
arts and our puny rational faculties
have been multiplied by the norms and
institutions of Reason intellectual
curiosity open debate skepticism of
authority and dogma and the burden of
proof to verify ideas by confronting
them against reality as the spiral of
recursive improvement gathers momentum
we eke out victories against the forces
that grind us down not least the darker
parts of our own nature we penetrate the
mysteries of the cosmos including life
and mind we live longer suffer less
learn more get smarter and enjoy more
small pleasures and rich experiences
fewer of us are killed assaulted
enslaved exploited or oppressed by the
others from a few oases the territories
with peace and prosperity are growing in
could someday encompass the globe much
suffering remains and tremendous peril
but ideas on how to reduce them have
been voiced and an infinite number of
others are yet to be conceived we will
never have a perfect world and it would
be dangerous to seek one but there's no
limit to the betterments we can attain
if we continue to apply knowledge to
enhance human flourishing this heroic
story is not just another myth myths are
fictions but this one is truth true to
the best of our knowledge which is the
only truth we can have as we learn more
you can show which parts of the story
continue to be true and which one's
false as any of them might be and any
could become this story belongs not to
any tribe but to all of humanity
to any sentient creature with the power
of wizz of reason and the urge to
persist in its being for it requires
only the convictions that life is better
than death health is better than
sickness abundance is better than want
freedom is better than coercion
happiness is better than suffering and
knowledge is better than ignorance and
superstition thank you
[Applause]